- It's like a vibe-coded thing, they're like,
and AI was like, and now here's the slash cookies endpoint.
It was like, I didn't ask for that.
- Right.
- Don't write that.
- Best part of hacking, when you can just,
you know, critical thing, right?
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
- Dude.
- One of the cool things about going to these live hacking events
is the ability to look at what you found
and what other people have found
and understand where the holes are in your methodology, right?
By comparing notes.
And thanks to Adobe sponsoring this episode today,
we have an opportunity very similar to that for you guys.
Okay, so here's how this is gonna work.
Adobe has agreed to give you guys a 10% one-time bonus
on your first valid report to any of the following products.
Listen closely.
Adobe Behance, Adobe Portfolio, Adobe Fonts,
AcrobatWeb, okay?
Those four.
And to get that, you have to use the code CTPBP0907, okay?
The description will have that information.
Also, this is valid through September 7th, right?
So keep that in mind.
Then what we're gonna do on top of that
is we're gonna do a hack along in the CTPB discord
for everybody, okay?
And we're gonna start looking at these targets.
And so what'll happen then is you guys will take a look at it.
You'll see what you can find.
Then we'll do the hack along and everybody will be
hacking on them, finding vulnerabilities.
I'll be hacking on them, finding vulnerabilities.
And then we can compare notes and see where we missed
the sketchy pieces of information or the leads
or the vulnerabilities themselves, okay?
So really good opportunity.
This is the kind of stuff that we have at Live Hacking Events,
and Adobe is bringing this to you guys.
So definitely check out those targets.
They're in the description along with the code.
Also, the Adobe team wants me to let you know
that they're gonna be at B-Sides Las Vegas sponsoring,
August 4th to August 5th.
Come check it out.
Go to their booth.
Have a chat with them.
They'll also be at DEF CON in the Bug Bounty Village.
So if you see anybody with Adobe swag or whatever,
don't hesitate to come up and say hi.
All right, that's it.
Thank you, Adobe.
Back to the show.
What's up, hackers?
I am pulling myself away from a live hacking event right now
to give you the TWIB segment for this week.
The This Week in Bug Bounty segment
is where we cover quick hits on news
that you need to know about,
even if we're doing like an interview
or something like that.
So here's what we got for this week.
First up is the platform panel on triage
at Bug Bounty Village DEF CON.
This is a super stacked lineup.
Guys, listen to this.
Michelle Lopez from HackerOne,
our boy Michael Skelton, aka Kodingo,
from Bug Crowd, our boy Inti from IntiGridi,
Eddie Rios from Sinac, Anthony Silva from Yes We Hack,
and moderated by none other than CTVB's own J-Rock,
okay, who has been on the pod several times.
Amazing hacker and was once on the triage side as well.
So this is gonna be a great panel.
Definitely check it out Saturday,
August 9th, 3:00 PM at DEF CON.
All right, next up is Yes We Hack
is making their debut in Vegas.
They want us to let you know that they're gonna be around.
Swing by booth 2367, meet the team.
They've got a really awesome group of people there.
I know specifically Alex Brumann has done a lot
in the hacking community.
Lots of really talented people.
And the Yes We Hack team, they've been pushing out amazing content.
So if you're hitting Black Hat, definitely stop by and check them out.
Up next, very appropriately, is a new dojo from Yes We Hack, okay?
And if you haven't checked out Yes We Hack dojos,
these things are freaking awesome, okay?
And this one in particular here as a little bit of like, you know, time,
time prediction tokens and some DC realization going on.
So definitely gonna be an awesome one to check out.
Last but not least, we have GMS gadget, okay?
And if you guys haven't heard of this, this is a new project by Kevin Mizu,
who's on our research lab team here.
He released this and I just, dude, I love Kevin's style.
I like right at the top here.
He's like, this project is inspired by the work of and then lists a bunch
of people from a 2017, a Black Hat talk.
And that's like at the very top of his page.
So humble, so giving respect to the original researchers.
And then he put together all of these gadgets.
So let me let me explain what it is.
I got a little overexcited here.
GMS gadget is give me a script gadget is what it stands for.
It's a collection of JavaScript gadgets that can be used
to bypass XSS mitigations such as content security policy
and HTML sanitizers like DOM purify.
So think about the episode with with Johan Carlson, right?
You know how much we talked about gadgets, right?
This is a place where you can find a lot of these gadgets
depending on what kind of, you know, what JS libraries
you have installed in your environment.
So definitely a good project to check it out.
We'll link it in the description.
Um, if any of you really are working
in a very tight CSP environment,
this is your new best friend.
All right.
That's it for today.
Let's go back to the show.
Where's your, Rezo, where's your house?
I'm already sitting down.
Come on, dude, all right.
Whatever, dog, whatever.
All right.
Here we are.
We're rolling.
Harley, Ari, welcome to the pod.
I'll do some swim arm flaps.
Okay.
There you go.
Nice.
Thanks for that.
Now I'm going to have to redo the intro.
Yeah, sure.
All right.
We're rolling.
Harley, Ari, welcome to the pod, guys.
Thanks so much for having us.
Yeah, thanks for having us.
Happy to be here.
Um, so here's what we do, you know, when we come on the critical thinking podcast,
we drop some bugs.
So, um, Harley, before we even, before we, you need to earn the right to get an introduction
here on the pod.
So, um, dazzle us with a little bit of a bug story, um, and then we'll move into introduction.
Yeah.
So, I mean, honestly, none of my bugs are really all that impressive.
Um, but you know, Joseph, I think you had a buddy on the pod.
His name was Aaron a couple of months ago.
It was a great episode.
If you know, go check that one out if you haven't seen it.
Um, but when I was watching that episode, he was talking about hacking applications.
And that was a topic that I had spent a lot of time doing.
Um, and it turned out like the blog that kind of inspired my research into that area was actually
his.
Um, and so it was super interesting.
So when I was pin testing for a company, I was, I came across this like support portal
and when just interacting with it, I would see a bunch of post requests to this aura
endpoint that I never really saw before.
Right.
I'm sure you guys all have probably seen this.
Oh yeah.
And so when I came across that blog, I just like, I was Googling, like, what is this aura
thing?
I came across that, um, and just following it like step-by-step, you know, was a gold mine
and was able to, to pop, you know, some access to things that were pretty critical, like getting
into support portal tickets, things like that, seeing attachments.
It was crazy.
And so that kind of like led me down this rabbit hole of like,
wanting to do this at scale for bug bounty.
Like bug bounty.
Because this was before I'd ever done anything with bug bounty before.
And so, um, I, if, if you've ever kind of popped that bug, it's very tedious.
Like you have to start by like enumerating all the custom objects.
Yeah.
You take all those objects and you have to like query each one by one.
And then you have to validate like, okay, here's this ID, use that ID to download this
file.
And then you have to then open the files and check the responses.
And some of it might be like intentionally public and not sensitive.
And so you kind of have to like manually validate that.
And so it was the perfect thing to try to like write a tool for, to do if you're trying
to do it at scale, but I've never been a great like programmer.
I've never been able to write code very well.
Um, and so it wasn't until I started working at hacker one actually, where I, uh, I partnered
with a buddy of mine and we kind of like created like this V1 of this tool.
And then we started just throwing against like project discoveries, chaos list and black
out everywhere.
Yeah.
Um, and then anyway, that just kind of like led to probably my first floor, like flurry
of bugs, um, that I ever got in bug bounty.
And it all kind of like started from errands, you know, blog posts.
So I just wanted to call out that, like that dude has done some really cool stuff.
And so having them on the pod was really cool to see.
Yeah.
He's still finding stuff.
He's speaking for app omni at black hat.
I think this year, um, like on one of the main stages, I'm pretty sure about, um, even
more findings and that's amazing.
Wow, dude.
Yeah.
I, I also really liked the, the, um, the thing you said there, the flurry of bugs.
I like, I was thinking like swarm flurry.
Like, I like the, the visual aspect of that.
Um, and surely there are those times, you know, when we're hunting where, you know, you
find individual bugs or whatever, and you try to extrapolate them as much as you can, but
it is really cool when you find a pattern and then you spray it and you just get a ton
of bugs flowing in.
Like that was when I'm, when I did this research on Grafana with the unauthenticated SSRF back
in, um, 2020, that was like one of the craziest times of my bug bounty career.
Cause it was just multiple crits every day for like weeks coming off of that research.
Um, flurries of bugs, man.
They, they feel great.
Yeah.
It's really cool when you have like a technique or you, even if you find someone else's technique,
um, and then you just kind of like learn how to capitalize on it and it can just kind of
keep paying you dividends throughout, throughout your journey.
Um, you know, now, nowadays I've been able to turn that into like a V2, you know, script with
vibe coding and just actually built this thing out that like, you know, really helps with automation.
And, and, you know, so it's, it's really cool.
Like I'm a lot more dangerous now with, with AI being where it is because now when I have these
types of ideas, I can actually turn them into, to tools and scripts where I couldn't do that before.
And so.
Yeah, dude, you've been, you've been putting out a lot and I've been, I kind of want to pick
your brain on this, uh, you know, cause I know your job at HackerOne is not a walk in the park.
And I, and you're also doing a bunch of stuff here, um, with Bugbani Village, with Disclosed,
with all sorts of stuff.
Um, so we'll, we'll get to all that.
But you've earned your introduction.
All right, guys, this is, this is Harley Infinite Logins.
Um, and, and we've got Ari here as well.
Uh, these guys are both the squad at the HackerOne live hacking events.
You know, when you, if you ever make it to an H1 live hacking event, they, um, they are the faces
that you see and you, uh, you know, hang out with.
Um, so that's how I know these guys, but, um, they're also running Bugbani Village at Defcon,
which is something we kind of wanted to, uh, double click into for this episode is kind of
talk about what we can expect this year.
Um, and, and man, it went amazing last year.
Uh, last year was like a knockout success.
Um, so I'm really, I'm really looking forward to, um, to this year.
Um, so, I mean, I'm, I'm looking at the doc here, guys, uh, you know, where do we want to start?
Do we want to talk a little bit about, uh, what you guys have planned for Bugbani Village?
Um, uh, at Defcon, um, let's give them both a quick intro first and just to clarify to
everyone, Bugbani Village is totally independent of like stuff that HackerOne has going on.
You know, HackerOne, of course, supports it, encourages it.
And I think it's also a sponsor, but these guys are doing this independently of that.
So definitely give them a lot of support and praise for that.
Tell them, thanks.
If you're under them at Bugbani Village, or even on social media, or if you're tuning
in, um, online or watching the recordings later, cause it's, um, uh, it's a big workload.
It's a big lift for them to do that.
Um, and it's really cool.
They do that for the community.
Hmm.
Yeah.
See, I thought we were giving them an intro, right?
So do you, do you want to like,
I mean, I mean, on the docket, we have information about them that you didn't
say like lots of it here.
So that's really what I'm, what I'm pointing out.
Okay, fine.
Dude, fine.
All right.
Let me say, let me say, uh, Justin, I'm partially offended that you didn't ask me for a bug.
You know, like, I know I'm a shitty Hacker, but you know, Ari, dude, we added you to this
call like five minutes before this episode.
I know, but that's the thing, you know, like, whatever.
Don't worry.
Oh, hey, I mean, if you, do you have a bug?
You want to talk about it?
I do have, I do have, I do have a bug.
Listen, listen, dude, like if I was coming on a pod and somebody like on the fly was like,
Hey, Justin, tell me about a bug you had.
I would be like, uh, you know, I didn't really think about a bug in advance.
I wasn't, but that's the thing.
You know, I'm always prepared.
You know, that's, that's a cool thing.
No, what you got, man.
Uh, no, again, I, I do agree with Holly.
I definitely, my bugs are not even close to any of the things I see in my hacking events.
Like, like, I feel the shittiest hacker when I see a show and tell.
It's like, dude, like you think you're a hacker and you see those things
like I'm so crappy, but yeah.
Uh, I, I do like, you know, a lot of the, um, you know, idors and authentication issues
and, and APIs.
And I feel like the APIs especially are like non, you know, not the main focus of a lot of
people, you know, a lot of people go straight into web apps and, and, and, you know, the easy
stuff or like the, you know, uh, they, they look for the idors and the cross-excript and all the
things, especially if you're not like super, super technical.
And I think sometimes if, if you find the proper endpoints of, you know, uh, APIs and you find the
swiders, uh, the, the endpoints, um, that that's what I like to do.
Uh, and then I saw like.
One by one, like all the endpoints and see, you know, what they do and, and, you know, the
authentication should they be, you know, using credentials or do you need a token for it?
Do you need a permission or something?
And I am very good at doing the shitty, you know, manual work that nobody wants to do.
You know, maybe you're probably going to write automation.
There you go.
Paul is going to buy code shit.
I'm, I'm literally like one by one, like one tab in the burp, uh, or Kylo, whatever you use,
you just like creating one tab at a time and, and like trying the, the endpoint.
And I have found so many bugs that were super cool.
And, and, and some of the things that you find there blows your mind.
I, I remember this one, I was just in a web app and like, again, got the swagger and start checking
an endpoint and I find the same point, which is this kind of the real, you know, like there's
like slash cookies or something.
And I'm like, why, why do you need this?
You know, I start accessing it and suddenly it brings me all the cookies of the people logged in
at the time.
And I did, dude, I don't even know what, what that was there.
It was in production and it was, it was like, this kind of be real.
And I'm like, why is this being used?
Like someone spying on us, you know, like all those things.
And you will basically hit the same point and you get all the cookies.
And basically it's a session, you know, take over for any account that, you know,
it will be online at the time.
So you will try it like multiple times and you will get like different cookies for different usernames.
So again, nothing super crazy.
It's like literally like a repeater task, super easy to exploit.
But the severity of that, the impact of that and, and the things that some people miss,
because this was not like a, you know, new program is there.
And yeah.
So, so I guess the takeaway is like, you know, I, I love Swagger endpoints.
And I feel like there, we need better lists to brute force some of those endpoints.
Sometimes, you know, those are not extremely, you know, uh, be school there.
Um, yeah, I remember the, the kite runner stuff by the asset note team really helps
with all that too, right?
Like the, the brute force software specifically designed for the APIs.
Um, and, and I think that is a great shout though, because like the, a lot of people will focus
on like the, the main app and the APIs that power those main app, but there's also a client facing,
you know, API sometimes that has weird stuff attached to it, uh, and, and doesn't have the
same security boundaries as the API that powers the main app.
I do.
I do think that, yeah, I've had a lot of success fuzzing, I think on, um, organically found paths.
So a lot of times you'll be hacking app and there'll be some API calls,
like you're talking about Justin and, um, they're like six or seven paths deep.
And I think very few people are then like taking that and then truncating it and like
fuzzing at each level.
And a lot of times at one of the, at like the third level deep, you'll find the swagger file
or whatever else.
And the, the cookie disclosure reminds me of like, um, Django debug mode enabled or whatever,
where you can get that exact same thing.
It's like, why did devs really need cookies of active users?
They, they never need that.
So why is that in any kind of, uh, like, why are there ever dev endpoints that do that?
It's like a, it's like a vibe coded thing.
They're like, and the AI was like, and now you here's the slash cookies.
I hit point.
It was like, I didn't ask for that.
Right.
Don't, don't write that.
Um, oh my gosh, man, that's great.
Well, Ari, dude, I'm impressed, man.
You're impressed with that.
That, that is shitty.
I mean, there's not even a clear, like a clever bug, but you know, it's, it's good, man.
It's good.
You know, I guess I know that, I know that I've run into you guys mostly in your, your community
management, um, roles at each one, but it's great to sit down and talk some, talk some technical
bugs with you guys.
Um, so, um, yeah, I guess let's go since, since we're doing more thorough, thorough intros here,
Harley, and we'll do you first and then we'll move to Ari.
Can you give us a little bit of a history of how you ended up in the bug bounty world?
Like where, where did your, where did your hacking journey start?
And, and why did you end up where you're at now?
Yeah, man.
So, I mean, I, I started hacking at like 14.
Um, you know, back, back then I was playing this game online.
I, I, I've heard so many stories start out this way, but I was, I was playing this game online.
Um, and some dude tried to fish me.
And so this is like 2010, like fishing wasn't quite as prevalent as it is today.
Right.
Um, but he's like, Hey, add me on Skype and we're going to do this thing.
And long story short, he ends up dropping a fishing link and I've never seen this before.
And, but I noticed like a few things were wrong.
Like I said, like dot TK in the domain, the like copyright, a year in the footer was like a year
out of date.
There was like a broken image on the page.
So like, I could tell like, Hey, this wasn't legit.
But, um, I also was like, you can't just clone a website.
Right.
So like, I just thought it was the coolest thing ever.
And so I started begging the dude.
I'm like, bro, you gotta teach me how to do this.
You gotta teach me.
And he just, yeah, no, but also please.
That's great.
So he just, he just blocked me, you know, and I never, I never hear from him again.
Um, so I spent like the next two weeks coming home from school, just like Googling,
like how to make fishing websites.
And so I'm starting to play with all this stuff, playing around with like, you know,
dark comment and remote administration Trojans and things like that.
And, um, I had no idea what the hell I was doing.
It was very much a script kitty.
Um, but that's what kind of led me down this path.
Right.
And, um, when I found out that there was a school nearby that had a cybersecurity program,
I was like, I was like, I think this is what I want to do.
So while I was in high school, I just hit them up and I'm like, Hey, can I like sit in on this
ethical hacking class?
And they're like, okay.
And so I was like able to get exposure and it kind of solidified, like, yeah, this is what I want.
Um, so I started on that path, got an associate's degree in cybersecurity.
And then after that started working kind of like traditional help desks as admin type stuff,
doing a lot of like firewall config, you know, management of active directory, things like that.
So I did that for about four years at an MSP, um, before I had an opportunity to finally go to
DEF CON actually back in like 2019 was my first year going to DEF CON.
Um, and I kind of just scraped up enough money to like couch surf and, and make it there.
Um, but once I was there and like in the environment of, of all the other hackers, it kind of just,
I don't know, like something, something clicked for me where I always wanted to be a hacker,
but I got stuck doing this like sys admin stuff.
And at some point I started thinking like, oh, hacking is only for like smart people.
And I'm not, I'm not able to do that, you know?
Um, but I don't know, like, I just realized like, if I'm going to make it happen,
like I'm going to have to be the one to make it happen.
And I started going down like the OSCP journey, just learning a lot, consuming as much content
as I could about this stuff, finding local communities.
There's like a local security meetup here in Portland called RainSec.
That group is awesome.
And it helped me a lot.
And I don't know, just really trying to, uh, brute force my way into becoming a pin tester.
And I finally made that transition in 2020.
Um, at that point, I just, as I was learning things, I would write about them.
You know, like I'd watch like an IPSC video, um, learn a new technique or two and be like,
okay, like instead of saving it as notes on my computer, I just put like published it on a blog.
And honestly, it was because I kept switching computers and I didn't want to like,
I just wanted to always have my notes with me.
Um, but other people started messaging me and they're like, Hey, this is really helpful.
It's really valuable.
Like it was somehow getting a lot of traction as a blog.
Um, and then that kind of like transitioned into, well, Hey, if people like this content,
let me make YouTube videos about it.
So I did a YouTube thing for a little bit.
I got like 10,000 subscribers on YouTube that I'm just not, I'm just not active anymore,
but I used to upload a lot.
Um, and that's when I created like the infinite logins brand and everything.
So I did that.
And then, you know, it was pin testing.
I became a security operations manager for a bit.
So doing a little bit of like blue team work.
I also managed like another pin tester.
And then eventually like, I just, you know, HackerOne reached out and they're like, Hey,
you want to come do community management, manage our pin test community.
I was like, sure, let's do it.
That's when I met Ariel and started working at HackerOne.
Um, I've been there now for the last three years and being in that environment,
meeting people like you, like, it's really kind of like fired me up to do,
you know, bug bounty and give that a shot and transition.
And that I'm not gonna lie.
The transition from pin test mindset to bug bounty mindset is a whole different, whole different piece.
Um, but yeah, I've been able to kind of overcome a lot of that and
started having success in bug bounty this past year, actually.
And I'm working on the ebook right now to talk about my bug bounty kind of like journey
and how I really found that success and like what worked differently for me.
And so that's, that'll be coming soon.
Dude, what the heck?
How are you finding time to do all of this stuff?
You're working on the ebook.
This is okay.
Okay.
So anyway, we'll, we'll, we'll, we'll come back to that.
Well, I want to go to the first.
Yeah.
Okay.
Go.
Yeah.
So the first thing I want to say is I'm going to introduce Ari in just a second and let him
introduce himself.
But I just want to mention that I feel like this arc of like finding, like being a hacker or something
awesome to do, and then like kind of radically pursuing, getting to Defcon, like getting a security
job, then getting to Defcon and then like, you know, basically doing cool stuff and writing about it.
And then, you know, other people encouraging you to do that.
And then following like existing hacking content creators, and then eventually creating content
yourself feels like just such a journey that so many people have been on.
It just really works.
Right.
And I do think that like, what you said, like, I, I realize that like, if I'm going to do this,
I have to do it.
I think that kind of like radical self-belief, even if it comes with a lot of imposter syndrome,
was like super true of my story and has been true of so many other people's stories.
So anyways, I just wanted to highlight that, like, if you are up and coming or,
or if you are like, um, kind of unsure of yourself, I just feel like the, the, um, the,
the patent or like the, the blueprint is laid out there, right?
It's like, just get so stoked to be at Defcon with a bunch of other awesome hackers,
hold that in your eyes, like your goal or whatever, and then use current existing free content out
there from like content creators or, you know, this podcast or whatever else to then like, just
like learn and feel your learning, but make sure that you're sharing it because then that encouragement
that comes from people that are like, oh, you found that or, oh, this idea or this lead or whatever
will then like help you kind of create a complete the arc.
Right.
And keep going.
So yeah, super cool.
Ari, do you want to give us, uh, your intro?
What got you into hacking originally?
And then how did you end up where you are now?
Yeah, definitely.
So I won't make it super long and boring, um, with my pen test alive, but definitely I started
the whole hacking situation with, when I was higher at Deloitte, one of the big four, you know,
consultancy.
So, um, I didn't hack much before besides, you know, cracking some video games or like,
you know, and by cracking, I mean, copy pasting a file to a folder, that type of cracking.
And, or, you know, like hacking my sister's laptop, like whatever, you know,
like that kind of thing, but I was never thinking about it as a, as a career.
Right.
But I was in the university doing like, you know, engineering and things like that.
I was not having fun.
Uh, eventually I, I, yeah, I got hired at Deloitte.
I, I started doing pen test and I definitely learned everything I know from, from there.
Um, because you know, that got me in a path, you know, I was shadowing someone.
They were teaching me.
They were super, uh, you know, friendly.
They were a great team.
They're still my friends today.
And that got me to like pen tests over pen tests and pen tests.
And, you know, consultancies, right?
It's like, you are the expert on everything.
And you learn, dude.
Like I, I used to travel to different countries and, and, you know, like doing pen tests.
And I wasn't an expert, but I was like, I was getting shitty payments.
And, and, you know, but I was investing in my career.
Like I'm learning.
I like it.
I'm traveling.
I'm, I'm, I don't care if I, you know, I kind of have to pay my lunch with a credit card.
That was, that was kind of my thinking.
Yeah.
Right.
And that's real, by the way.
It's, it's, you know, it used to happen, but I was like, okay, I'm investing in my, in my, my career.
So I'm okay with it.
And, and eventually, you know, I moved to a different company.
Um, and at the time I was trying to go to Defcon, like Defcon to me was like a passion.
I was like, how do I go there?
How do I make my company to pay for my trip?
Because like, you know, I don't have the money to pay the whole thing.
You know, it's super expensive.
So I was like, okay, this training budget.
And, you know, I was doing my best to, you know, get my training in Defcon, you know, specifically.
Eventually I went there, um, luckily multiple times.
And I remember 2017, uh, Defcon, I was there with these, you know, the company paid for my trip.
And I have this friend, Niemensek.
He's currently doing back money as well.
He used to work with me at the Lloyd as well.
We were pentesters there.
And he was doing back money, back money hunting at the, at the side.
At that time, back money hunting is not what it is today.
You know, it was a struggle to like, I will see his, you know, all the payments.
It was like one critical, $50.
You know, like it was really growing up.
It was trying to be what, what is, you know, it is today.
Um, I'm talking, you know, before 2017, but then by 2017, there were like, like hacking events
and like things were getting better.
And Niemensek was, you know, you know, invited to Las Vegas, like hacking event, 702, which is,
you know, uh, big, big thing.
And at this time we, we, you know, hack one used to do it in, in this rooftop with a pool.
And like all hackers were super, you know, like, I don't know, dude, like you will go in there and it's like, it's a rooftop and hackers are hacking.
And like people are having dreams.
So sick, dude, I was like, I don't know what this is, but I want to be in, I want to be part of this.
However, like, I don't give a crap.
And you know, like if I need to do my money, I will do it.
If I need to work here, I will do it.
I don't care.
Um, and a lot of people will just, you know, they're just the old swag and, you know, like,
I did it myself as well, you know, but getting free drinks.
It's Vegas.
Everyone's partying.
I was like with a different mindset, dude.
I was like, I'm not working the hell out of this.
You know, I'm talking to every single person who has like a hack one T-shirt or something.
I was talking to everyone, meeting people and I made friends there.
Like, you know, I met some, some cool guys, uh, the VP of engineering at the time,
Hacker one, uh, Alec, he was great and Alex.
And, and yeah, we started talking and like, again, working and stuff like that.
And I'm like, dude, I am a hacker myself.
I have a huge community in Argentina.
I want you to come to Argentina for like, you know, I want you to come to Buenos Aires.
So, you know, it's like, I want this in Buenos Aires, in my country.
And I'm very passionate.
You can tell.
So I'm helping you.
I mean, I'm like, I don't care.
I will help you to do it.
And they were like, okay, we'll see.
And I was, I was like, okay, it's not my job.
And eventually 2018 September.
I received an email and it's like, Hey, you know what?
We are actually going to Buenos Aires.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
Yes.
That's like so cool.
And I'm like, come in, you know, like I can help with whatever.
And they were like, yeah.
Can you help us with, you know, a venue for like a happy hour or like a venue for this?
Or like, uh, we also need your accommodation for local hackers because you know, we don't know
Buenos Aires and like, we don't speak Spanish.
So, you know, we need translation.
And I was like, I will help you.
I don't care.
I, I, of course I didn't get paid.
It was like all passion, uh, all passion pressure for me.
And eventually that happened.
So we did the, you know, that event.
H1 5411 in Buenos Aires and yeah, I invited like, I don't know, 20 hackers or 30 hackers,
you know, uh, from the local community.
And, and I think they kind of got mind blown because a lot of those hackers
got their first bounty in that event, including myself, including the LEC, which, you know,
is one of the hackers I was collaborating a lot.
Who, who was the target?
Uh, the Paranoids, um, at the time, you know, they're not called the Paranoids anymore,
but the Paranoids were the target.
And yeah, at that time, well, Stoke was here.
Franz Rosen was here.
Inti was here.
Um, meals.
Um, I don't know.
A lot of big names.
What a lot of lineup.
What a lineup.
And, and, but also at the same time, it probably wasn't like a huge budget or something,
because we also invited these 20, 30 people from the local community.
You know, I, I, I got a bunch from Buenos Aires specifically, but also some from Uruguay
or Chile or Brazil.
So, and yeah, I, I made my first bounty there, like paid bounty.
I got like 20 or 30 duplicates before that, which was like very frustrating.
Yeah.
So sad.
Um, and, and, and yeah.
And, and I got like a, I don't know, collaborating with Delizy, it was like a 12,000 dollar bounty
or something.
And we got six for us.
It was like, that's massive.
Yeah.
Imagine from coming from dupes and dupes and zero bounty to actually getting, you know,
six K total for the event or something.
Again, that's great for the event to see what people are making today for the event.
It's nothing.
Six K is not, but for someone new coming from dupes, first bug triation and I had an event
and getting like, you know, two criticals or something.
It was 12 K total.
Um, it was insane.
And do you, do you think that that triggered a bunch of Argentinian hackers to like really
dive in and like stick with it?
Yeah.
I mean, uh, just for you to know, like none of the evolved, Leandro, one of the greatest
hackers that I know.
Yeah.
Um, I invited him to the life hacking event and he got his first bounty there.
Wow.
Um, Delizy, uh, he's also, you know, doing great.
Um, pen testing, back money hunting.
He also got one on first block or, or the first bug.
Um, but yeah, there were a lot of people from, from Argentina that saw this as, okay, this
actually, you know, it's real, you know, uh, it, it works.
So they started, uh, you know, hacking from, from there.
And, and after organizing that event or helping actually, because of course I didn't do everything.
Um, I got hired for hacker work.
So that, that's where the VP of marketing at the time was like, dude, I love this.
You know, I want you to work with me.
And I'm like, sure.
You, I mean, I'm definitely on board, but I, I kind of didn't trust him at the same,
you know, at the same time.
I was like, yeah, it's too good to be real.
You know, um, you put yourself out there, man.
I mean, you, you networked your way into it right at that event.
And that is definitely something that a lot of hackers underestimate the power of.
Just ask.
Right.
This is Douglas Day's phrase.
Just ask.
I mean, you literally went up to Alex Rice and were like, Hey, let's do this in my country.
And then it happened.
And then it changed the lives of tons of local hackers.
I mean, that's an insane story.
And, you know, maybe, maybe it's a little bit of, uh, you know, of luck, of fortune there.
Right?
Like, you know, he says, okay, yeah, sure.
You know, we'll do it.
And then bonus editors or whatever.
And then, you know, he's in a meeting a couple months later and, and, you know,
oh, this comes up as a potential venue.
And he's like, actually, I think I've got someone who can help us with that.
Like, and that just kind of tips it over the, the, the edge a little bit.
Right.
Yeah.
Um, so if you're getting out there, you're talking, you're, you're putting your dreams out
there.
Um, it definitely helps that, that manifest.
I think, um, guys, I'm not, I'm not gonna lie, man.
It's, it's pretty sweet getting to sit down and hear y'all's story.
Cause we've, we've seen each other a lot, but I haven't heard these backstories.
Um, so thanks for, thanks for talking about that, um, this time.
And, and, and I did want to ask you guys, because, um, obviously, you know, Rezo and
I are, uh, living the full-time bug bounty life, really leaning into bug bounty.
Um, and we talk often about like the fact that bug bounty is like our dream, you know?
And, and I wanted to ask you what brought you into the community management side?
Um, you know, and you guys are a very unique breed because very few people have tasted the,
the pen tester, the, the, uh, book bounty hunter lifestyle, and then choose to do,
you know, a, a, a different, a different side.
Um, and I think a lot of that comes from, you know, the love that you give to the community
and that sort of thing.
But I'm wondering what your, why, why you made that decision to move into, into community,
um, in the, the bug bounty world, rather than, um, you know, staying on the, on the technical
route and doing that from your day to day.
And it feels a little bit, Oh, you go ahead.
I'll let you point it to one in a minute.
It feels a little bit like skeleton and coding, or sorry, skeleton and hack Luke.
Cause they kind of were big hackers, but then decided to like support the community,
obviously in a slightly different way, but kind of interesting.
Yeah.
You can, you can direct the question.
I'll give that to Harley first.
Well, the fact that you, you know, are like, Hey, you guys are kind of like skeleton and
hack Luke.
It's insane.
Uh, thank you.
I'll take that compliment.
Um, but no, I mean, honestly it wasn't necessarily purposeful for me.
Like it just happened naturally.
Like it keeps happening naturally.
Like every time I try to pivot into, you know, doing something different where it's like
focusing on more technical roles, I always just end up doing things like this.
And I think it's just my passion for helping others.
And, um, and, and really like kind of like trying to lift other people up.
And like, I think that that just is kind of what's creating a lot of this.
Um, even when I was going through school, I was,
I was just creating community.
Like I founded the cybersecurity program or cybersecurity club.
Um, and brought people in.
And me too, dude.
Come on.
Give me some.
Let's go, dude.
That's how we do.
Yeah.
But it's just like, I feel like, you know, you guys have talked about bug bounty being
sometimes lonely and whatever.
It is.
Like, I think that part of it is just looking to try to find people that you can
experience life with, like, you know, experience and have a journey together and
share wins and share losses, keep you motivated, whatever.
Um, and then it's just in that path of like always looking for other people that I can kind
of like share things with.
I've also been wanting to help them and then exchange, like they've been helping me.
And I don't know, like, just, I feel like my career has always benefited when I bring other
people around that also are trying to like help people.
And it's just, I don't know.
It's not really, it makes sense, man.
You've got, you've got something that, that pulls you towards community that pulls you towards
people, um, rather than, you know, necessarily towards the technical piece.
And I, I feel that man.
I mean, when I'm around you, I'm like, I, I like, you know, every time I see you,
I come up and give you a big hug.
So, um, that's, that's great, man.
And, and Ari, I'd like to hear your side as well, because you were, you were doing the
consultant life for a while.
You know, you were traveling around, you were hacking stuff.
Um, and then you, you, you know, you chose to jump on this bug bounty role where you're
helping with the life hacking events.
So what, what made you make that transition?
Yeah.
So, so for me, it was like, again, you know, like I was sharing like the passion to, you
know, be part of this, like to be part of this community, like wanting hack, want to be here,
uh, and try to replicate what I was seeing in Vegas and, you know, with all the top
hackers and things like that.
And, and what keeps me here is also, you know, I always say it's kind of,
corny, like so it sounds cliche maybe, but it's like, we are changing people's lives,
you know, but we are providing opportunities for different people that in, especially like
some people around the world that maybe are outside of the us, right?
Like I am from Argentina.
That's what I say.
You see that specifically, right?
I mean, that, that 12,000 dollar bounty was what?
Probably the salary of a lot of your friends for a year.
Yeah.
100% like, you know, making that salary for me, it's like, dude, um, this is life-changing
and, and providing that same opportunity to others, not only in Argentina, but Latin America
or like India or like whatever, you know, like different countries that
think about this.
Like you're making literally the same exact money than someone from the us is making, you know,
like you, you get the critical, you just, you make a 20k bounty or something.
Someone in India can make the same bounty or like I can do it if I invest the time or have the knowledge.
And the equipment required is so low compared to other industries too.
Right.
I mean, like if they can get a computer and some of them even start with a phone, right?
I don't know if any of the Argentinian hackers have, I know so many Indian
hackers that have just started hacking with their phone.
It's insane.
Like sometimes they, they literally watch some YouTube videos.
They, they watch and have sex streams or something.
They, they start doing rigor or understand something and, and they, they get a bug.
And suddenly it's like, okay, that, that is life-changing.
And it, you know, again, so I was saying it sounds cliche, but you know, when you face
people in life hacking events or different events around the world and they come to you and thank
you for it, it's life-changing.
It's like, I feel appreciated.
And I feel like what I'm doing, it's, you know, it's worth it.
And literally I had people come over to me and say, dude, I love you.
And like, I don't even know you dude.
Like who are you?
I am this username, right?
Like, oh, you, you're this username.
Oh, amazing.
And dude, thanks to you.
I bought a house and I bought a, my parents' house and I bought a car.
And you know, when they tell you that it's like, it means something for them.
And maybe what I did, it was just like, you know, invite them into a program or at the time
making them a Pentester or providing a, like, having them any buy, you know, whatever.
And, and that changed, you know, the life.
So that, that is what keeps me going.
Honestly, I, besides that I'm a shit hacker, right?
And I kind of do what, you know, top hackers are making, but, um, definitely, you know,
that's kind of what keeps me going, keeps me motivated.
And, and, you know, it's hard.
And sometimes it's when you see all the hate on social media and, and you always get like 90, 90%
negative stuff and 5% positive, you know, like you don't see all the positive things.
So sometimes it's complicated to, you know, stay motivated or positive and, and try to keep
doing the same things.
But then when that single person comes to you and say something nice, uh, it makes it work.
Yeah.
I mean, they're only so passionate and negative because it is life-changing, right?
It's like the difference between the getting paid and not, especially like you said, for,
for some, for some hackers in certain countries, it's like, it's actually life-changing.
And so even if they're in the wrong, like they've got to fight for it tooth and nail,
because if they do get paid, you know, it could, it could literally buy, you know, their,
their entire family of food for the next six months or whatever.
So.
Yeah.
And like the equipment, like think about this, like just to put a close one in it,
like maybe you're hacking from your phone, like you were saying, and maybe making that
bounty allows you to buy a Mac.
Sure.
And that is your working tool for the next five years or something.
Right.
You know, like it, it, it's life-changing and sometimes we don't realize that.
Cool.
Well, yeah, I mean, the main, uh, goal for this episode was to hear about you, both,
both you guys, but, but also especially to hear a lot more about bug bounty village.
Why don't you tell us like in like two sentences, like kind of the, the, uh, origin story of bug
bounty village, and then, you know, maybe some, some highlights about things that you are excited
about this year.
Did anything change relative to last year?
You know, maybe who are some of your key speakers?
So yeah.
Two sentence origin story.
And then let's talk about this year.
Cool.
I'll, I'll start.
Um, so yeah, but, but bunny village kind of came to be a thing that we didn't expect to happen.
We submitted our application and we heard, you know, other people were trying to get a bug bounty
village for a couple of years.
And we just submitted ours thinking, okay, we'll throw our names in the pool.
And I guess they love their application and they were like, yeah, let's do it.
And so we had three months last year to, to pull it together.
And yeah, the, the response was really, really positive.
Uh, this year, some things are definitely different.
Um, but not, not a ton.
I mean, it's going to be similar to last year.
We have a lot of the same speakers.
Uh, people like Haddix, NT, Nahamsec, uh, Ryanorator, some dude named Ryanorator.
Who's that guy?
Yeah.
I'm excited.
We've got a lot, a lot of awesome speakers coming in and doing stuff.
Um, we've also got some new things that are happening this year.
But before I talk too much about that, Ari, did you want to talk anything more about the origins?
Yeah.
I mean, that's what I was saying.
You know, like, I think it has always been like a passion project for me as well.
Like, we didn't have a back money village.
To me, it sounded stupid.
You know, like, why, why are people going to red team village to talk about back money?
I mean, I know it's related, but also it's like, it's because they don't have the space.
It's because they don't have the space.
You know, like I want to learn more about back money.
It's a career.
It's like a, it's an industry.
Like why we don't have a space in the biggest conference of hacking, you know?
And to me, it was like, we need it.
We need to be there.
We need, we need a space.
It was obvious.
Um, but at the same time as how he was saying, like, I didn't think we were going to get accepted.
And, and also it depends a lot on, you know, if your employer allows it, if you have the time
to invest, if you have the money or you can get the sponsors to, to run it because it's so freaking
expensive, dude.
And we, we were not prepared.
100% not prepared.
I will be honest with you.
I submitted the application form on the last day from a hotel room.
We like, and, and by the way, thanks Jessica, my manager, which was like, have you submitted anything?
Fuck.
I think we could all say thanks, Jessica, for about 15 different things.
Thank you, Jessica.
And, and, and yeah, and, and she was like, damn, boom.
And, and I submitted it.
And of course I put all our work in the submission.
It wasn't like, uh, just like, you know, AI generated or something.
Um, and they, I guess they like it.
Um, and yeah, we were, you know,
super happy and also like immediately after like panicking a lot, uh, because it was like,
okay, what the hell is DEFCON and now we're organizing something there.
And it's like, we don't know anything at all.
And we kind of still feel that way sometimes, but, um, uh, but yeah, I, I have to say that,
you know, the first year was, was great, uh, was definitely overwhelming, but also like,
we were super grateful with the support and, and, you know, all the speakers, including you,
just seeing, uh, that invested the time on the talks, but also the people that, you know,
was there trying to, to, to be a part of it, you know, because it's, you can do a village and you
can also not have anyone coming in or saying, ah, actually the red team village is six times the size.
I'm not going to be small space.
You know, like, and how was the space that they have, it's definitely small.
We, we probably need like 10 times the space.
Yeah.
I told them I, I, after the con, um, I walked up to, to the village leads and I said, I said,
if you give us 10 X of space next year, we'll fill it, like, give it to us.
And this year we got, I think what, 30% more space.
So it's not very, the podcast has grown a lot.
The industry has grown a lot.
It's going to be a long line.
I think it is.
Last year we were literally blocking.
The, the pathway, like for a lot of the whole DEF CON, like people were lined up, dude.
I literally know people who spent three hours waiting in line just to get inside the village,
which sounds crazy.
But when you really sit down and think about how many hours the like DEF CON as a whole is open,
like it's only like what, eight hours a day ish, right?
Eight to 10 hours a day.
So to spend three hours is insane.
That's, that's a decent portion of your experience.
Luckily there was a good amount of stuff going on in the line as well.
You know, like, you know, I, I know that me and, and, um,
some of the crew were kind of walking up and down the line,
talking about critical thinking stuff, giving out swag, you know, that sort of thing.
So maybe we can do some, some line entertainment again, cause it's going to be.
We can definitely do some line entertainment.
We're going to need it, man.
I think it's really cool.
Cause like, like a lot of the bug downy people that it's typically before bug downy village,
all of us would be pretty like distributed, right?
Like we might be at recon village.
We might be at red team village, you know, and now I feel like we actually have a home.
Um, and we can bring a lot of people
into like the central place and exactly that.
Like, even though there's a big line, um, you know,
there's a lot of cool swag and different challenges too.
We also have lined up and we can talk about some of that this year, but you know,
in addition to people like you coming in and, and just kind of hanging out in line
or talking to people, um,
we're going to also have challenge coins that we can give people a solve while they're waiting in line.
We're going to have a, a CTF this year where people can actually try to compete.
Um, so definitely happy to talk more about that for sure.
Yeah.
What's, what's the deal with the CTF?
Who's, who's making it?
Um, how's it, how's it going to be run?
Yeah.
All right.
So I'm actually really excited about this because I, I didn't really want a CTF.
I, I ultimately what I wanted to see have us like do was let's get some real like programs in
and let's do like actual, almost like a mini life hacking event type thing.
Right.
Um, and the logistics of that knowing firsthand from being on the hacker one side
would be a nightmare to actually try to pull off for a number of reasons.
Maybe one day we'll figure it out in the future.
Um, but in reality it wasn't going to happen this year.
And so we were like, well, what else can we do to where it's still going to be a hands-on
hacking activity?
And, um, you see a lot of CTFs where it's like, here's a password hash, now crack it.
Okay.
You get a flag, like cool.
Um, but not what we wanted.
And so what really, what we envisioned was like an intentionally vulnerable web application
that you don't have instructions.
You're not guided.
You don't have a path.
It's just like, here's this environment.
Go hack it.
Right.
And maybe there's a program page that talks about what's in scope and what's allowed and
whatever.
Um, and so we wanted it to feel like a real bug bounty situation where you're just going to
this website and you find a bug and you write a report.
And then that report gets triaged and you get points based on your report.
And so that was kind of like the vision.
Thank you.
And so we started reaching out to a bunch of vendors to try to make this happen.
And then we probably talked to what, like a dozen different people and like a week trying
to, trying to make this happen.
And then we finally came across, uh, these guys, uh, based out of Dubai, they're called
CTF AE and they were just super passionate about, about the project.
We hopped on a call and they were super excited about it.
Um, they've done really big CTFs for black hat in, in that region before.
And so they definitely have the experience that they, you know, to do something at the
scale we need.
Um, so yeah, they, they've kind of like taken the idea and they've expanded on it and ran with it.
And so now we have this web application, but it's not just one, it's like multiple applications.
I have APIs and there's LLM components and it's like this holistic system.
Yeah.
So, all right.
I want to, I want to, I wanted to add that, you know, it's definitely kudos to them for being so
passionate about it as well, like, and, and trying to take it to the next step.
We, we haven't seen some things and it looks great.
Uh, and again, it's like has an LLM and like different type of box.
It's not going to be the typical, oh, it's a cross-excripting and you get the flag.
You know, it's going to be a lot of things.
And we're also going to be having volunteers that are, some of those are triashers from
different platforms and they will be triaging your box.
So it's definitely, we kind of scale it.
If we do like a real triage scenario where, you know, we'll have thousands of submissions
and they will triage the whole thing.
But at least we'll, you know, review the report and we'll see, are you making a one-liner?
Dude, you're not going to gain points for that.
You know, like you need to write a proper back money report to actually, you know,
get some extra points.
So eventually what we expect is that the new people coming to back money will have a
learning experience of the whole thing, right?
Like you read the policy, read the policy, understand the scope.
You actually hack the scope.
You find the bug, you submit a report and someone triages it and you get a communication there.
So that is, to me, it's great because it's, you know, again, like for the new people will be
super, super, uh, educational, right?
They will learn the whole process and they'll also hack, have fun.
Heck yeah.
And then for, yeah, then for the experts like you guys, like you will have a nice challenge
because you know, the, the, the challenges will be, some will be easy, of course, no hanging
through it, but some will be like, you know, the, one of those, you want to quit and, and, you know,
break everything and, and you will be stressed.
So, uh, we expect to have, you know, a challenge for, for all the, all the experience levels.
So that's awesome, man.
Yeah.
I love the idea of having a CTF that is, that like represents the bug bounty process, right?
The, a lot of the, the ambiguity of bug bounty, right?
Where you're like, uh, you know, the thing about CTFs is, oh, there's always a solution,
but you're, you're emulating that a little bit here by giving them a full app with minimal
instructions, right?
And, and, you know, they may be going down this path and it's actually, you know, there's not a bug
there, you know?
Um, but, but this, this seems like an accurate representation with the reports, with the,
where do I go?
What do I do?
You know, sort of, uh, having to overcome that paralysis to solve these, these ETFs.
Yeah.
100%.
And, and just, just to add to that, it's like, these guys are building it.
They first created the whole web app without the vulnerabilities.
And then they are adding specific vulnerabilities.
So it's not like, you know, everything's broken and you will just, you know, everything is
destroyed by, by the start.
It's like, they actually create a whole app working functionally.
And then they are adding the bug.
So this, you know, also will feel like, um, harder.
It's again, like, you don't know where to look.
You will have to test all the features, all the functionalities, do all the, you know, like,
like you do in background, you create an account, you, you buy something, you know,
you, you do something to actually have more scope, you know, see more API endpoints.
And dude, heck yeah.
Let's go.
This is what I'm talking about.
I have a question.
Are you all going to deliver dupes?
That, that's something I wanted to do.
Actually.
Uh, I proposed that.
I, I was thinking, you know, like, what if we create a dupe?
So they also get frustrated from that.
And, you know, like we actually get the real experience.
Um, I think it might be a challenge for us to do that.
Uh, but we're thinking that maybe, you know, uh, we'll have specific challenges for in-person
people at Defcon, uh, because we cannot triage thousands of reports in real time.
So we'll gate it to in-person people at Defcon.
And maybe, you know, we can come with something up and see if we can dupe some bugs.
Maybe the first three flags are valid and then the other ones are dupe.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
You could have a lower threshold for the dupe.
Like, since you have a count on the number of flags, maybe it's like, if you're the,
if you're more like, if you're the top 10, it's not a dupe, but if it's greater than 10,
you get a big warning.
It's like duplicate, you know, you were the 11th person.
Or you got some even less points because you, you, you, you were later to the party,
you know, like really like in back money.
So yeah, that'd be super cool.
Or, or what you could do is just everybody's first bug is a dupe, no matter what it is.
It's like, everyone's got to do the first one.
And then it starts like a two hour timer and it's like, okay, reopened, uh, triage,
you know, like that sort of thing to give them that little, like, huh, you know,
sort of feel like I love it, dude.
Rick, that's awesome.
And just to be clear, the, the CTF will be open to the internet.
It will be something that anybody, even if you're not going to DEF CON, you can still participate.
Um, we're just going to get the triage experience to be in-person attendees only
just because we can't scale triage.
Yeah.
Oh, absolutely.
That makes sense.
Um, guys, I will, we'll put it up on the screen now.
Uh, Richard, if you could put up the, the view of the DEF CON layout that they have there.
Um, looks like we have a little bit more space this year.
What, what kind of stuff do you guys have in mind for the space?
Uh, that's, that's different from last year.
Yes.
We, we made some key changes to, you know, you'll notice like there's a podium with the
TVs on either side.
We had that same type of setup last year inside the village.
Um, but last year we kind of set it up more classroom style where you had tables and you
could sit down with a laptop because of just how crazy the line was and how many people got
frustrated for not being able to come in.
And you know, people were literally sitting on the floor.
Like we just decided, look, like ideally we would have space for tables.
So people can bring laptops, but we are going to value, you know, just letting more
people in their laptops.
Smart decision.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
Smart, smart decision.
So, so we removed the table so we could fit more seats.
So it's 30% more like floor space, but then also taking the tables out,
probably gave back another 30 or 40%, I would say.
Right.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
Like I think last year we had, I want to say 30 to 40 chairs.
Whereas this year, I think that number is like 70.
And so, um, at least for right in front of the podium.
And so that, that'll be helpful.
And then we also kind of are dividing the room in half.
So we're going to have these dividers where, you know, you'll have the speaker doing whatever
it is that they're doing.
And then in the back half of the room is going to be more of like a quiet area where there's
couches and ottomans that people can come in and sit on.
And the idea there is we'll have the leaderboard for the CTF up on a TV back there.
And so if they want to come in and sit down and hack inside the village and chat with friends,
meet people that network and collab with, they can, um, and, and hopefully not disrupt the speaker too
much.
Yeah.
I, I think that's a great idea.
And I, I think also just speaking back to the CTF versus real bug bounty thing, the way that these
live hacking events started in the first place was people at DEF CON were just like, Hey, I'm going
to go hack on this target.
You want to do it with me, you know?
So like, I think there's this, this component of, um, the, the whole beauty of bug bounty is its
accessibility in a lot of ways.
Right.
And so at the end of the day, if you guys have a space where people are just going to sit and
hack, um, and we say, you know, here are the top, you know, 50 programs or whatever from each,
you know, each platform or whatever, pick, pick them and, and go after these public targets,
right.
Together.
Then that could also be a really cool environment.
Yeah.
I think, I think the, the future definitely looks like, like that.
And we definitely want to do something in that regard in the future, but it's also a huge
challenge when, when the back of the, the back of the village of DEF CON is platform agnostic.
Right.
So, um, in order to avoid having like preference or avoid having like a single platform there or like a
sponsored platform that pays, you know, like, um, you will need to make them all welcome and everyone
should have, uh, like space and organizing that with all the platforms that want to participate.
It's like chaos.
And also like if triage, you know, doesn't triage on time, like you need suddenly five
different triage from different platforms.
And it's like, I don't know how to scale it.
I think it's the future.
We're just not there yet.
Um, but definitely it's interesting.
I mean, I mean, absolutely.
And I, and I think, I mean, without the platform's permission, you can grab the top five, five from
HackerOne, top five from, from Bugcrowd, top five from YesWeHack, top five from Integrity or whatever.
Right.
Throw them up on a board and say, Hey, these are the top five programs, you know, by, by payouts.
And, you know, sure.
They're not going to get paid out on the spot.
So it's not going to feel like an LHE quite as much, which, which does affect the experience.
But at the end of the day, if you're sitting there collabing and your buddy's like,
Oh, I popped something like, heck, I'm walking out of DEF CON with cash positive.
What's the heck up with that?
Um, then I think that would be really, really sick.
A hundred percent.
And I mean, you know, I kind of feel like we're, we're creating that environment already.
Right.
Where it's like, yeah, yeah, we're not broadcasting specific programs necessarily, but
people a hundred percent are making connections, going to their hotel room and popping bounties.
Like I've, I've talked to many people who did that exact thing last year.
For sure.
Um, I am looking at this doc and I am seeing a very cool badge.
Uh, what, what's going on with this?
How do we get our hands on these bad boys?
Oh man.
All right.
So these badges, we had badges last year.
Um, the, these are like last year's except nothing like last year's and way better.
Um, and anyway, we partnered with a guy named Abinov Hackerware.
Uh, he does a lot of great work for a lot of villages and hacker cons.
He was kind of like the genius that made this badge come to life.
And it's got like this cool, like blinky matrixy type effect in the background where it like rains
binary code.
You can't see that here really on, on the still image.
Um, but we've got videos that we can share.
And anyway, I'm just super thrilled for this badge.
You'll notice there are a few buttons at the bottom.
If you have a keen eye and we didn't have this last year.
And so these buttons will do things.
And I don't know how, how much we want to describe here.
Uh, but we do plan on integrating various challenges into our badge.
And so, um, you'll see challenge coins from various platforms that may or may not resolve
to a binary flag that punch into this badge and make the badge do different things.
So it'll be really cool.
Um, I'll leave it at that.
Ari, do you want to talk about it?
Yeah.
I, I feel like since this pro is going to be airing at, you know, end of July,
like we can share a little bit more, uh, there will be like days from Defcon.
Uh, but yeah, like the challenge thing, uh, the challenge coin thing is
something like at least with hacking, we have been doing it for the last three years.
I haven't created these easy, you know, approachable challenges that are fun.
Um, for someone that never solved like a crypto challenge before.
And by crypto me, we mean cryptography, not, you know, cryptocurrencies.
And it's kind of fun.
And, and you normally have like two sides of the car.
So you have like some hints and, and you can, you know, do some, some cool stuff.
Last year, we did it for back on a village.
And this year we, you know, we put that into sponsorship.
So, um, Hagrid is actually sponsoring the coins, uh, again, and we'll have this
challenge that if you've sold, you know, you can get these, you know, buy another thing.
And then you, you'll type it in the, in the, in the batch.
So ideally you'll, you know, you will have some lights.
You will have a couple of challenges and you feel unlock everything.
We'll be able to tell that you unlock everything.
We'll see.
Maybe we have some giveaways or some.
How many badges are there?
Yeah.
So we have 400 of these blue ones that were given away.
Okay.
Um, and that's shout out to inspected for that.
They were the sponsor who made that happen.
And so thank you inspected for, for making this possible.
How do we get there?
Yeah.
So to get them, they're going to be given away at random.
Um, you kind of have to earn them right place, right time.
Also, if you're doing great things for the village, we'll recognize that.
Um, so if you come in and you're helping people or, you know, you're volunteering or whatever
the case is, we'll definitely hook you up with a badge.
Otherwise, you know, say, stay in the loop on our socials, be on the lookout for agenda.
Last year, we were giving people who were like the first people in the village every day.
We were giving them badges for like the first, you know, 40 people that showed up or something
like that.
Um, so yeah, there'll be lots of opportunities to get your hands on one.
I would say maybe follow, you know, all of the socials and look for announcements.
Heck yeah, dude.
I'm going to be I'm going to be looking for that.
I also have another, another announcement to the badges to to share.
Oh, really?
Yes.
Okay.
All right.
Well, well, hold on.
We got it.
We got another announcement about the badges.
What's the announcement with the badges?
So I mentioned we'll have 400 of these blue ones, right?
Oh, but we're going to have another variant.
And the other variant is actually one that if you want to make sure you get a badge,
you can purchase one.
Um, and so we've got a, we've got a green variant that is limited.
We're only making 200 of those.
Um, and those are actually available for pre-orders right now.
If you're watching this at the end of July.
Nice.
Um, and so if you go to shop.bugbunnydefcon.com, you'll be able to purchase yourself a green badge
and you'll want to only we're not shipping them.
So you'll need to purchase it and then pick it up inside the village during Defcon.
Um, but yeah, we do expect these to sell out.
Oh, heck yeah.
Heck yeah.
They will.
I love it.
Green, the green ones for the green hat.
Right.
That's exactly.
It's, um, it's a custom edition.
Yeah.
We, we try to make it a little bit different, more exclusive.
And also, you know, just for, for everyone listening to know, it's like, you're literally
helping the village to be run by purchasing a batch.
Uh, we are going to take those, you know, those badges money to pay.
A lot of other things are like, uh, costing us a lot of money to run.
So, you know, keep that in mind.
If you like the batch, definitely get one.
If you like to help us, definitely get one as well.
Um, but yeah, just remember, you need to pick those up in.
That would be a cool booth for future years.
Like, um, basically like contribute to the, like, basically what's it called?
Like fun, like fund the bug bounty village.
So like when you're sitting at that table, if you find a bug sitting there, like that
money goes to the bug bounty village, that would be really cool to do.
Dude.
Yeah.
Guys, give us, give us a handle, you know, that we can add in as a collaborator on some
of our reports and donate some, some money to the, to the bug bounty village.
That would be really cool.
The handle is infinite logins.
So, uh, Richard, just Richard just beep that and change it to Rezo.
If you don't mind.
Yeah, no, my gosh.
Um, all right guys.
Well, thank you so much for all your hard work on the bug bounty village.
Super appreciate that.
Um, uh, we'll, we'll pivot a little bit now to, uh, Harley's stuff.
He's got a ton of stuff going on.
Um, uh, so hardly you, this is what I was saying before.
Like, dude, you, you are producing so much crap right now.
Like I can't, I don't understand how you do all this stuff at one.
Like I was like, and it, and it's all high quality.
Like the disclosed news newsletter, dude, we've been working on the critical thinking
newsletter for a long time.
And then when I saw the quality of that newsletter, I was like, dang, he's doing some work.
Um, and then now you're telling me you've got an ebook and you're working on bug bounty village.
So how the frick are you doing this?
Honestly, dude, I've just been kind of obsessing lately.
I think I'm getting really inspired by like the capabilities of AI and like what we're able to do
now.
I'm able to be way more productive than I ever have been before.
Um, the newsletter thing, to be honest with you, like, I think in the past, like two years ago,
I wouldn't have never been able to do it, but because AI is where it's at, I've been able to build
automation that, you know, it does a lot of the work for me.
Like I'm literally scraping, you know, Twitter and YouTube and all these different things.
If someone links to a blog, I'm scraping that.
I'm summarizing things and I'm having to automatically rank like high quality content.
And so, and then I vibe coded this like front end.
That's like, let's me easily see the feed of all the different, but the book.
I saw that in the doc, man, Richard, put, put the, um, behind the scenes one up on the,
up on the screen right now that he's got like content feed V2 with like this beautiful screenshot.
I love what vibe coding does for us, man.
Like that we can so easily build these little like backends and stuff that make our day-to-day
data processing so much easier.
Yeah.
And literally like I only show the feed screen, but like, this is like a whole
like newsletter editorial app where you can approve content, reject it, move it to the prep section
where you reorganize and, and, you know, edit, and then you click generate and it writes it
in your voice using AI.
Like it just, you know, it also allows for the human in the loop component, which I do think
is very valuable.
Like instead of spending, you know, 20 hours a week doing this all manually, I'm spending like
two hours on the weekend and I'm still spending time and I'm still doing, you know, the human in
the loop component to actually make sure the content is high quality.
Um, but it's, it's enabled me to do that where I couldn't have before.
Yeah.
When I saw one of your posts recently, I think that I was like, oh, I wonder what sassy is using
on the backend.
Like what alternative to beehive or whatever else is he using?
That's crazy.
It was just vibe coded.
That's sick, dude.
That's absolutely sick.
And then on top of that, we have disclosed online, which we've mentioned on the pod before,
uh, you know, sort of aggregating hacker profiles across all the bug bounty platforms.
Um, so tell me a little bit about your, about your vision for that and what your, what your
hopes are for, for where that'll go.
So for that, honestly, I just was bored on a weekend.
I think it was like Memorial Day weekend or something.
And I had an extra day and it was like, what do I want to build?
Um, and I had this idea of like building the hacker directory.
And so I, I did that.
And I don't know, like what really happened is I spent like 24 hours kind of building a lot
of it just for myself for fun.
And then, uh, I saw somebody post online.
It was actually the, the things for sharing the screen.
Yeah.
This is, this is it.
Um, for the other one, the hacked in.net is what I ended up coming.
Uh, but before he released that he posted about it and that tweet was like getting a lot of traction.
And so I was like, oh, like, actually I've been already doing this.
So that kind of like inspired me to just grind it out for the next couple of days to actually
push it and make it live.
Um, and so yeah, that's what this is.
And dude, it's just really cool to see like what you can.
It's pretty, man.
It's, it's a pretty website.
I dig it.
Um, and, and, you know, we, we talked, we covered it on the pod before.
Um, is this going to be something that you're going to continue to work on you think?
Or, uh, is this sort of like a vibe coded project, um, that, that like, like for example,
verifications takes a lot of work on the backend, right?
If you're going to send verification emails or something like that, is that something you plan
on integrating or.
Honestly, it was a side thing that I just kind of whipped out and people thought it was cool.
I used it as like a lead gen for my newsletter.
Cause I was also releasing the newsletter around the same time.
Oh, Hey, speaking of the newsletter, I know that we mentioned it a minute ago,
but I have been getting so many subscribers to my, to my email list for my blog posts via yours.
So thanks for that.
Dude.
Yeah, of course.
Again, happy to build up people.
Right.
And you're building me up by giving me this platform, like happy to happy to return the favor.
Um, but yeah, like the, the newsletter you can, by the way, you can find it at getdisclosed.com.
Uh, would love if you would take a moment to, to subscribe, but that was really the intention.
Once I built this, I was like, okay, it could be a cool lead funnel for that.
This it's not a startup.
It's not a platform that I'm, you know, going to make money on or really investing any more time
in other than what it's at today.
Um, do I think that there's a million things we could do for sure?
I could even expand this to where, you know, we started advertising programs and, you know,
people start leaving reviews about programs or even reviews about hackers.
Maybe that might be dangerous, but there's a lot.
There's a lot we could do.
We can finally organize the union.
Done.
Oh my gosh, dude.
But no, I mean, my, my focus, my focus is, is on my full-time job.
Uh, my focus is on Bug Bounty Village.
And then, and then the Disclosed Newsletter with, with any of my extra time.
Nice man.
Well, it is an amazing product.
Uh, I, I really appreciate the way that you've used AI to optimize your workflow and still
deliver a really high quality result.
Um, and I, I'll say like newsletters are, there are some people that are really into newsletters.
I don't really consume newsletters that much besides this one.
Uh, and, and, uh, one of the ways that I consume it is, is through your X posts, um, that you do,
where you kind of take a, an X version of that newsletter and, and put it into the, into X.
And I think that's a really, really awesome, um, thing you're doing there.
So definitely would love to see you continue doing that.
It's good to know.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Um, all right.
Oh, dude.
So, but, so we're going back to the Disclosed thing though.
It got hacked a little bit though, right?
Can you, can you talk a little bit about that story?
Cause I thought that was hilarious.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I, I actually tried to make things better and that's how I got hacked.
So let me, let me, let me run through it.
So, um, you know, I've got to the front end.
And the way that I, I always vibe code apps is, is I build the automation separate.
And so, you know, the automation and all that like is actually run through, um, in a,
then which is like a low code automation platform, like make or Zapier.
And so I do a lot of the automation through that, populate a Supabase database and then
build the front end using like lovable or, you know, whatever other vibe coding tool you like to
use.
And when I was building this out, a lot of the vulnerabilities that I introduced actually were
because of Supabase configurations.
And so what I found after I built this, I originally was going to let people self-register
to create an account on the directory.
I later decided to remove that and turn it into like a lead funnel where you have to subscribe,
um, to the newsletter to get an account.
But when I first created that, I didn't remove, like I removed the front end of Supabase
authentication, but I didn't actually remove it from like the Supabase config.
And so people could hit the API directly and still self-register an account and basically,
you know, force them into the, into the database.
And so that was one bug that's less critical.
Um, but that was one bug that got, that got sorted out.
The other bug that was way more critical was I noticed because I just kind of was like poking
at my own app a little bit that in the response, you would leak all of the information about,
you know, the, the tape.
Like if you query a record in the table, you would see everything about that user,
which is intentional.
It's all public data, but there was one field that I didn't want to be exposed,
which was because when you would self-register and originally you would provide an email.
So I was like, okay, how do I fix this?
And so I'm researching how to fix this in Postgres.
And I came across views in Postgres.
And so I was like, all right, I'm going to make a view that basically queries all the same stuff.
It just excludes the email field.
What I didn't know is that when you create a view in Postgres, it doesn't respect, uh, RLS policies
like tables do.
And so it, it actually is configured with the permissions of the user who creates it,
which is really stupid.
But that means when I created this view,
I essentially gave everybody unauthenticated admin access because my view was created as an admin user.
Oh, man.
Oh, no.
Brutal.
Oh, geez.
Yeah.
So I had a researcher, uh, who, you know, decided to, to kind of pwn me and go through all
my records in my database and change all of the profile images for everybody to his avatar.
Oh, dude.
And then change the bios of everybody.
And, you know, it's like, like, yeah, I think you took it too far.
You could have, could have done better.
But I was just happy that he worked with me to help me figure out what the, what that was.
Were you able to undo it?
Yeah, it was pretty easy.
It was just like, well, once I thought it was an RLS problem.
And so like, I'm spending a ton of time, real level security.
I'm spending a ton of time, like trying to solve, like, like, okay, why is this not working?
I thought I had that restricted.
And it wasn't until later I figured out the view thing.
Um, but he actually inspired me to build Vibecode, another tool.
It's a, it's a, you know, like a Supabase security scanner that will, you know, grab
all of the different tables out of the swagger that's exposed in Supabase and then query all
those and test, write records and all this stuff.
Um, and so I was able to kind of build that out.
And honestly, I think there's a product opportunity.
Where is it, Harley?
Where is, where's the tool?
Uh, it's private, man.
Give me the tool, Harley.
We were just talking about that on the pod.
We just like, what was it a couple of weeks ago?
We mentioned, uh, shell found a, you know, some weird quirk with Supabase, right?
Where you get less than or greater than, uh, U U IDs.
And then we were like, oh, we should create a scanner.
And then.
Yeah.
I've already got the scanner.
Um, I actually saw that and I'm going to implement that into the scanner.
Well then you have to share it, right?
Then, then it all of a sudden enters public domain and it's open source and you have to share it with us.
So yeah, sure.
I'll share it for $9.99 a month.
Oh geez, here we go.
He's, he's got the, he's got the bug.
He's got the legion, uh, bug.
Now that's great though, man.
And, and, you know, big, big fan of obviously sharing with the community, but also big fan of keeping the stuff that you, that you want to keep private, private.
That's the name of the game with bug down.
Um, so, but yeah, it was cool because it, it allowed for this cool story.
And so like I posted about it on Twitter and like it went crazy and, you know, I definitely used a clickbaity title of like, if I coded this and got hacked.
And a lot of people were just like retweeting it without reading it and making fun of it.
But I actually tried to provide value in the thread.
And anyway, I thought, I thought it was a pretty cool story.
And I do think there is an opportunity.
Like so many people are vibe coding and shipping apps right now that they don't know what they're doing.
Um, I think if someone were to step in and try to release a product that's specifically
for like securing vibe coded apps, I think that they could really.
Can someone explain why this is not a feature for GitHub?
Like why, why do we not have like automated GitHub code review?
I just don't understand.
Yeah.
It's obviously not gonna test the whole app.
Like it probably wouldn't have worked for your view.
Right.
I don't know if a view is like, um, a state via code.
If it's not, then it wouldn't have worked in that case.
Right.
Cause it's like a platform as a service vulnerability or SaaS.
Like, you know, it's like in the, it's actually in the DB, not in the code itself.
But yeah, we definitely need that.
Yeah.
That's exactly right.
Like, and I think that that's the play, right?
If someone built a tool that's specific to like querying the database, um, and securing that,
because I do think you're right.
Like there's probably a solution out there that can secure the code.
Um, but it's like the misconfigurations in the database that I think are really leaking a lot of stuff.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
Man.
Yeah.
I'm glad you jumped on that opportunity though with Supabase.
Cause a lot of people are, are, are using that and setting that up.
Um, so it's good to see some, some technology going out around it.
That's very reactive.
Um, all right, guys, I think that's all we had in the doc.
Make sure you check out lots of things.
All right.
Listen, listen closely here, guys.
We got getdisclosed.com.
Subscribe to the newsletter.
Great newsletter.
Love it.
We've got bug bounty Defcon.com, right?
That's where you get your badges.
That's where you learn about bug bounty Defcon where we're all going to be come this August.
We got disclosed online.
If you want to get that aggregating hacking, uh, profile.
And if you want to see some of Harley's AKA infinite logins, past YouTube videos,
you can find that on his YouTube channel.
It's just infinite logins, right?
Harley.
Yep.
Exactly right.
Awesome.
Well, Harley, Ari, thank you guys so much for coming on the pod today.
We will see you at, uh, at Defcon and bug bounty village.
Thank you so much for having us.
Thanks guys.
Thank you so much.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for watching to the end y'all.
If you want more critical thinking content, uh, or if you want to support the show,
head over to ctbb.show/discord.
You can hop in the community.
There's lots of great high level hacking discussion happening there on top of the masterclasses,
hack alongs, exclusive content, and a full-time hunters guild.
If you're a full-time hunter, it's a great time.
Trust me.
I'll see you there.
Thank you.